but the democratic party did officially
name its presidential nominee last night
joe biden thanked delegates last night
from a delaware high school
where his wife jill used to teach with a
celebratory assist from his grandkids
night two of the virtual democratic
national convention included speeches
from former presidents bill clinton and
jimmy carter
along with republicans like colin powell
and cindy mccain
widow of senator john mccain and it was
notable that most of those
speeches focused on building up joe
biden rather than tearing down the
president as democrats aimed
to demonstrate unity even though they're
physically far apart our ed o'keefe
reports now
from biden country wilmington delaware
delaware is proud to cast its 32 votes
for our favorite son
and our next president our friend
delaware
joe biden a roll call like no other last
night is democrats from maine to the
northern mariana islands
georgia to guam washington d.c to
washington state
officially nominated joe biden
the former vice president and his wife
jill celebrated with their grandchildren
at a wilmington delaware high school
where jill once taught it was there that
she later spoke on behalf of her husband
and acknowledged that many teachers like
her are struggling with how to work
during the pandemic you can hear the
anxiety that echoes down
empty hallways biden said her husband
would carry the nation forward
in its time of need how do you make a
broken
family hole the same way
you make a nationhole with
love and understanding and with small
acts of kindness mr biden has called
himself a bridge to the future of the
democratic party
and the night highlighted rising stars
in every election
we choose how we will create a more
perfect union and the party's former
leaders joe biden must be our next
president
former president bill clinton delivered
his most stinging attack to date
against president trump at a time like
this the oval office should be a command
center instead it's a storm center
there's only chaos just one thing never
changes
his determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame
and yet again democrats gave air time to
republicans
like former secretary of state colin
powell with joe biden in the white house
you will never doubt
that he will stand with our friends and
stand up to our adversaries
never the other way around and cindy
mccain the wife of the late senator john
mccain who narrated a video about how
her husband
and biden worked together it was a style
of legislating and leadership that you
don't find much anymore
there was also a focus on issues like
health care with one video featuring
activist
adi barkin who suffers from als
after i was diagnosed the president
passed a tax bill
that put my health care at risk
so i went to washington d.c
barkin lost his voice from the disease
everyone living in america should get
the health care they need
regardless of their employment status or
ability to pay
one little piece of procedural business
they had to do last night caused a
little confusion for folks
runner-up bernie sanders was also placed
in the nomination they asked new york
congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez to formally
place him in the nomination
she was a good team player and did so
but there was a little confusion about
that it's just a formality
as for tonight former president barack
obama is set to address the convention
he's expected to talk about his eight
years of partnership with biden
and also to push for americans to vote
this fall
and of course here in this building
behind us in wilmington delaware will
also hear tonight from the vice
presidential nominee
kamala harris gail
ed thank you